let's say I have a matrix where
everything below the main diagonal is a
zero and I'll start just for the sake of
argument let's start with a 2x2 matrix
so let's start with a 2x2 matrix so I
have the values a B 0 and D so instead
of a C I have a 0 there so everything
below and the main diagonal is a 0 so
what is the determinant of this going to
be let's call that matrix a so the
determinant of a is going to be equal to
ad ad minus B times 0 so that's just 0
so you don't have to write it so it's
equal to a times D now let's say I have
another matrix let's call it B and let's
say it's a three by three matrix so
three by three matrix and let's say it's
entries are a B see you got a zero here
then you let's say you have a D here E
then you have another zero here another
zero here and you have an F so once
again all of the entries below the main
diagonal are 0 what's this guy is
determinate what we learn several videos
ago that you can always pick the row in
the column that has the most zeros on it
that simplifies your situation so let's
find the determinant along this column
right here so the determinant of B the
determinant of V is going to be equal to
a times the sub matrix if you were to if
you were to ignore a row and column so a
time's the determinant of D e0f and then
minus 0 minus 0 times its sub-matrix so
you could cancel out or times the
determinant of its sub-matrix that row
and that column you get b c 0 f vc 0 f
and then you have plus 0 plus 0 times
you get rid of that row that column you
get b c d e b c d e now obviously these
two guys are going to be 0 I don't care
what these 2 by 2 matrices what their
determinants end up evaluating to so
these are both going to be equal 0
because we're multiplying by 0
I left with a time's the determinant of
this and the determinant of this is
pretty straight forward we're going to
have it's going to be equal to a times
determinant of this is DF minus 0 times
Z so it's just going to be DF so it's
going to be D so the determinant of B is
a DF notice the determinant of a was
just a and D now you might see a pattern
in both cases we had zeros below the
main diagonal right this was the main
diagonal right here and when we took the
determinant of the matrix the
determinant just ended up being it just
ended up being the product of the
entries along the main diagonal and if
you think that that's a general trend
that always applies you are correct we
can do it in the general case let's do
the general case so let's say we have
some matrix a and it is equal to it is
equal to a11 and then you have a 2 2
you're going to have a 0 right there and
then you just keep going all the way
down to a and N and this row everything
is going to be a 0 everything's going to
be 0 except for that last column this is
all a 0 right here so everything below
everything below the main diagonal is a
0 just like this one but we're doing it
in the general n by n case and
everything up here is well it doesn't
have to be 0 this is a 1 2 all the way
to a 1 and this is a 2n keep going down
so everything and the main diagonal are
above isn't necessarily equal to 0 so if
you wanted to find the determinant of a
we can do the same thing we did here we
could go down go down that first row
right there so the determinant the
determinant of our matrix a is equal to
this guy a11 times the determinant of
its sub-matrix so that's going to be a 2
2 goes all the way to a 2 N and then a 3
3 all the way to a and n all the way to
a n N and then everything down here is
these are all
Zero's these are all zero so once again
we have another situation where all of
the entries below the main diagonal are
zero so what's the determinant of this
guy right here and what you might say
hey what about the rest of that row well
the rest of the row is just a bunch of
zeros just like we had here it's zero
times the determinant of its sub-matrix
and then I've you minus and a plus zero
times the determinant of its sub-matrix
so on and so forth so we just have to
pay attention to this term right there
now the same argument we can do here to
find this determinant we can just go
down that row so determinant of this is
just going to be equal to let's write
out let's not forget our a11 out there a
1 1 and the determinant of this is going
to be a 2 2 a 2 2 times the determinant
of its sub-matrix get rid of its row and
it's column and you're just left with a
3 3 all the way down to a and n
everything up here is nonzero this is a
3 n and then everything below the
diagonal once again this is just a bunch
of zeros everything down here is a bunch
of zeros another another what we call
upper triangular matrix let me write
that down this whole class where you
have zeros below the main diagonal these
are called upper upper triangular
matrices triangular matrices matrices
just like that now we keep doing the
process over and over again if you just
keep following this pattern over again
now you're going to have the determinant
of this is a 3 3 times its sub-matrix
and every time the sub matrix is getting
smaller and smaller you will eventually
you will eventually get to a 1 1 times a
2 2 times all the way to a n minus 2 n
minus 2 times a 2 by 2 matrix over here
times a 2 by 2 matrix here that's just
going to be a n minus 1 and minus 1 a n
sub n this is going to be a sub n minus
1 n and then you're going to have a 0
right here so it's just the bottom
right-hand corner of our original matrix
is what you're going to be left with
and what is the determinant of this well
it's just the product of these two
things it's just this guy times this guy
- this guy times that guy but that's
just zero so the determinant of a the
determinant of a ends up becoming a 1 1
times a 2 2 all the way to a and n or
the product of all of the entries of the
domain diagonal which is a super
important takeaway because it really
simplifies finding the determinant so
what would otherwise be really hard
matrices to find the determinants of you
could imagine if this was you know 100
by 100 matrix now we can just multiply
the diagonal so just to make sure that
things are clear let me do an example
let's say we find the determinant of 7 3
4 - yes so we have zeros here so it's a
minus 2 1 and a 3 with a 0 here sorry we
don't want zeros there we don't need to
have zeros there 6 7 we actually could
have zeros there but we don't need to
have zeros there the 0 there you have
zeroes there just like that so it's
upper triangular matrix if you want to
evaluate this determinant you just
multiply these entries right here so the
determinant is equal to 7 times minus 2
times 1 times 3 so it's 7 times minus 6
which is equal to minus 42 and it's that
easy